hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game from the penultimate
round of the air things masters 2022
it's alexandre costeneux versus eric
hansen and uh alexandra has been having
a pretty tough tournament so far she's
13 losses zero wins and zero draws and
eric on the other hand is having a
phenomenal tournament maybe the best
tournament ever uh as uh he is uh well i
don't know if it's uh definite that he
will qualify for the main event but uh
he he is definitely very close so we're
going to discuss who qualified who did
it after the game but now let's check
out the game and what happened here as
it features a very very nice ending so
alexandra with the white pieces opens
with e4
that's not an e4 e4 with e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 sorry about that
uh and uh we have bishop to c4 going for
the italian game
bishop to c5 the joko piano is on the
board and now uh we have c3 going for
the main line knight to f6 and d4 now
now immediately striking in the center e
captures on d for c captures and bishop
to b for check and this is a position
you uh could see on the board uh today
and also 400 years ago as for example
knight to c3 is the start of the very
famous greco attack we've discussed this
a lot during the the past few years but
here
we have knight to d2 knight to c3
although it is very flashy but of course
if your opponent knows how to play this
with black uh it's been shown not to be
all that impressive over the over the
years uh so bishop to d2 is what's
usually played here alexander plays
knight to d2 uh we have d5 now striking
in the center e captures some d5 knight
captures
in both
players castle so castles castles and a3
asking black what do you do with the
bishop here so you could go back with
bishop to e7 but it is better to capture
here we have captures characters and
bishop to g4 eric doesn't want to stay
behind in development so he now develops
the bishop and pins the knight here now
alexander plays h3 saying that okay you
can capture here i'm going to capture
back and if bishop to h5 you can play
that but
for some reason everyone always captures
this knight so bishop captures an f3
queen captures and now knight to b6
attacking the bishop here bishop back to
d3 and now what do you do with the d4
pawn you can capture it with the knight
you can capture it with the queen and so
far uh knight captures on d4 has never
been played this position has been
reached but always queen captures on d4
was played and this isn't all that
impressive uh it runs into bishop to c3
and now look at white's uh attack here i
mean the the the bishop fair is just um
those are monsters the queen is uh ready
to jump into the attack it's very easy
to bring the rook into the attack so
black will have very hard time surviving
this so eric of course goes knight
captures on d4 and it is now as of move
14 that we have a completely new game he
attacks the white queen but he also
gives up the b7 pawn so alexandra grabs
it we have queen captures on b7 rook to
b8
attacking the queen and also trying to
uh go for a little trick here if uh the
a7 pawn is captured you can play knight
d6 and now how do you defend the bishop
here it's a very tricky and the white
queen is very awkwardly placed on a7
just to give you an example for example
queen a6 defends the bishop knight c5
and off with the bishop so this is a
terrible blunder but other other moves
aren't all that great for uh for white
either so instead after rogue b8
alexander goes back queen to e4 now
checkmate is being threatened on h7 and
eric defends it with the very aggressive
f5 so he defends and also grabs more
space here queen to e3 uh we still have
to be very careful if the knight moves
then both of our bishops are here on the
default so the queen has to keep an eye
on those bishops
and now c5 uh now the knight is nicely
defended here it's a great outpost you
can see that
alexander does not have a c pawn or an e
pawn to get rid of this knight so for
the moment the knight is staying there
and now we have rook 8 to d1 you could
also bring the rook to e1 also uh
definitely you can do this as the file
is also open but rook to d1 seems to be
a bit more natural the queen is still on
d8 we want to put the bishop on c3 and
that's uh that's how alexandra plays it
so knight's the d5 attacking the queen
now comes bishop c for pinning the
knight the king is still on g8 so eric
quickly unpins and now queen to e5
putting a lot of pressure on that
black king again the bishop is coming to
c3 at some point but we don't want to do
it just yet we don't want to give up the
bishop so here we have knight to b6
attacking the light square bishop and
now bishop back to a2 also a very
interesting line and i will just show it
because i know you guys enjoy very
interesting lines is bishop to h6 we
just threaten checkmate of course the g
pawn is pinned
so how do you defend rb7 defends the g7
pawn and now we play queen captures in
c5 now you can't capture the bishop here
because then we capture this knight and
then uh the other knight so that would
be completely losing so we have to play
rook to d7 to add another defender here
but now we play bishop g5 and now look
at this everything is hanging
the knight here is attacked twice the
queen is attacked if the queen moves
then the rook on f8 hangs and here
nothing is really good here for black
you have to play something like knight
f3 check we're gonna win this knight and
now again uh you can't go uh for the
rogue because the queen is hanging
you're gonna have to play queen captures
on g5 with check and after king h1 again
what do you play uh the rook here is
hanging you have to defend it queen f6
now bishop b3 and the game continues and
uh even though this seems to be better
for white uh
maybe uh from a human standpoint it's
not all that easy to decide to go for
something like this so that's why uh
alexander just brings the bishop back
bishop to a2 there's no reason to open
up your king like this if if you have
other options and uh well it would seem
that white does however after knight to
d7 here uh attacking the queen and
defending the c5 pawn it would not be
easy to continue this with white however
eric plays rook to e8 and now we simply
have queen captures on c5 knights the a4
attacking the queen and the b2 pawn so
queen to d5 now
uh offering a queen trait and here eric
just uh
picks back the pawn so knight captures
on b2 now comes rook to b1 uh and now
queen to f6 eric declines the queen
trade and now asks uh what do you play
here and you can see that you have to be
very very careful uh the the the knight
here is attack the this knight is
attacked the bishop the c3 would attack
both knights so it's a very very tricky
position so here we have rook f the e1
putting more pressure uh on black and
then now what do you play here well you
could play knight the e to check and
this is in fact very interesting knight
the e to check pretty much has to be
played and now after king to h1
rook b to d8 this is how black gets back
into the game however in the game rook e
d8 was played attacking the queen here
but now uh there is a problem uh here
alexandra plays queen to a5 and it
doesn't seem like there's a move that
black can play what do you play here
it's such an ugly position for for black
and you always have to be careful that
bishop the c3 once it comes it's uh just
not gonna be not gonna be easy uh so now
you didn't have to play queen to a5 you
could also offer a queen trade here you
could also offer a queen trade here but
queen a5 just keeps all the tension uh
without white really having any any
issues so here knight the d3 was played
uh you have to get those knights out of
that awkward situation now this is being
threatened this is being threatened a
lot of stuff hanging here but now rook
captures nb8 rook captures and queen
captures on a7 again
you can't capture on e1 because we
capture on b8 so here rook to f8 and
rook to e3 getting a rook out of harm's
way and how do you defend the knight and
this is now a real problem uh you can't
go here you can't go here you can't go
here you can't go here what can you do
you can't go here then the queen no
longer defends this knight so you could
play knights to f4 or you could play
knight to c6 and just attack white's
queen so there are some other options
but uh we're just gonna discuss the most
complicated one so with knight to f4 it
seems like black pretty much solved
everything but now comes queen to b7
uh putting uh
well defending that g21 that could be a
problem in some lines but now knight the
f2 with check king to h2 and now queen
d6 check we're gonna play king to h1 uh
it's our only move but still uh white's
position is not winning we have the past
a pawn and also just bishop to b4 will
win a lot of material so let's say rook
d8 and now we're going to play bishop b4
queen to b8 offer a queen trade we can
trade here captures captures and after
bishop c4 uh you can see that uh the
bishop pair is just much much stronger
than the night pair here and it doesn't
really matter what uh black plays
we're just going to show a nice fun line
for example if knight to f4 then we play
bishop b6 attack the knight and the rook
and it seems like you have rook to b1
checking h2 but not really because now
checkmate is being threatened and also
your knight is hanging so uh it's it's a
long line but basically it just shows
how the two knights are
uh
well they're just very very poorly
placed and it's not easy to get them out
so here eric tries knight to c6 instead
but now queen b7 uh knight to c5
attacking the queen once again and now
queen to b6 attacking the knight on c5
so knight back to e4 and it seems like
you're out of the woods but now rook to
d3
and again uh what can what can black
play here uh if you play uh something
like knight captures here then rook
captures on d2 and again you haven't
improved your position
at all pretty much if queen a1 check
it's not a problem the rule guards the
bishop and you're just going to start
advancing your your pawn here so instead
we have rook to b8
attacking the queen so queen to c7 and
now comes queen to a1 with check and now
comes the
the excellent part king h uh sorry with
check we have king to h2 and now what do
you play well you could grab the bishop
but if you grab the bishop then we get
bishop to f4 in uh and now uh what do
you play here with black the knight is
hanging uh you have to play something
rook the g8 let's say queen captures on
c6 and again uh everything is defended
our passport is alive we're gonna win
this game easily however eric uh uh
decided to play something else he played
knight captures on f2 and now of course
we reach the position from the thumbnail
if i will ever put this position on the
thumbnail
but if not uh feel free to pause the
video and find the winning move for
alexandra it's a forced mate in two so
while i give you a couple of seconds
and of course uh think of paul morphy
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this very
nice back rank mate and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course queen captures on b8 with check
and it was in this position on move 35
that uh eric hanson resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once the knight captures the queen then
it's rook to d8 checkmate and that's it
so of course after this queen captures
on v8 uh he resigned to the game uh so
it's a very interesting it's it's like
the uh uh reminds you of the of morphy's
opera house game as the queen okay the
queen didn't capture anything on b8 and
the knight was on d7 but still it's uh
very similar and if you you know really
know that game then you will always
remember uh to recognize such patterns
and you will find moves like this uh in
an instant
uh
alexandra gets her first win after 14
games so it's it was 13 losses in a row
then this victory against eric hanson
and then she lost the the final game i
think it was against dingler and uh but
also
you know if you have to win only one
game this is definitely the way to win
it by by sacrificing the queen so
congratulations on this very nice game
uh and eric well he had a brilliant
tournament regardless of this loss as
these are the standings you can see uh
the players on the left qualify for the
main event the players on the right do
not qualify so you can see that to
qualify ian nippon she won this
preliminary event uh with 29 points
followed by magnus carlsen and with 25
larissa vartemi with 24 and andreas
penco eric hansen in fifth place with 23
points and then with 22 we have dingler
and lee huang liam uh and vincent kymer
and players who did not qualify lavonna
abuse
and as you can see uh the the the young
youngsters uh like uh uh yes panko and
vincent kymer have well even vladislav
uh have qualified in front of some very
very strong names like
uh anish giri lavon
uh duda i mean okay dude is also very
young but he's uh i mean he was uh
one of the world's championship
candidates so uh
uh very nicely done by by both eric and
andy sipenko so we'll see what happens
in the final event an opponent she takes
the the preliminaries uh what will
happen in the final one uh we'll see
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and hope a lot of you found
this queen to b8 if not uh re-watch the
opera house game uh i'm pretty sure i
made at least one video on it uh i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to vm
uh and i would like to thank even
sterling pp poopoo
richard schwartz and iran urban for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day